>> Jon: WELCOME BACK, MY GUEST
TONIGHT IS THE FIRST MINISTER OF
SCOTLAND AND THE LEADER OF THE
SCOTTISH NATIONAL PARTY, PLEASE
WELCOME FIRST MINISTER
NICOLA STURGEON.
(APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Jon: WE'RE DELIGHTED TO
YOU HAVE HERE.
>> THANK YOU, I'M DELIGHTED TO
BE HERE.
IT'S VERY EXCITING, IF A LITTLE
SCARY.
YOU BILLED ME ON YOUR WEBSITE AS
A COMEDIAN.
>> Jon: DID WE DO THAT.
>> SO YOU RAISED ALL THESE
EXPECTATIONS I'M GOING TO BE
FUNNY.
AND I'M A POLITICIAN.
AS YOU KNOW, POLITICIANS ARE
REALLY VERY FUNNY, SO-- .
>> Jon: YOU NEED NOT WORRY.
THEY THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO
BE FUNNY FOR 17 YEARS.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: AND THAT DIDN'T WORK
OUT EITHER.
SO I THINK YOU'RE FINE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT IT.
>> THE GUY THAT IS TAKING
OVER YOUR SHOW, WHEN YOU
SADLY DEPART THE SHOW,  IS FIRST
OF ALL COMING TO EDINBURGH
TO DO THE FRINGE.
>> Jon: THE FRIDGE FESTIVAL.
>> AND I JUST WANT EVERYBODY TO
KNOW -- THE FRIDGE FESTIVAL.
>> Jon: ONE OF THE GREATEST
FESTIVALS.
>> JON GAVE A COMMITTMENT EARLY
ON BEFORE THE SHOW THAT NEXT
YEAR HE'S COMING TO EDINBURGH
NEXT YEAR TO TAKE PART IN THE
FRINGE.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW
LIKE A POLITICIAN, I WILL MOST
LIKELY NOT FULFILL THAT PROMISE.
>> I'M NOT THAT TYPE OF
POLITICIAN.
I KEEP MY PROMISES, JON, SO I
WANT YOU TO MODEL YOURSELF ON
ME.
>> Jon: THAT'S WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING, HERE IS WHAT I
FIND SO INTERESTING.
SO YOU HAVE PLEDGED, AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY, FIRST OF ALL, THE SMP
WON 56 OUT OF 59 SEATS OF
PARLIMENT, IT WAS UNPRECEDENTED.
SWEPT AWAY.
>> I'VE ALREADY WRITTEN AN
INQURY ON HOW COME WE DIDN'T WIN
THOSE OTHER THREE.
>> Jon: YOU THINK ARE YOU
SADDAM HUSSEIN, YOU GET 99%.
56 OUT OF 59 IS PRETTY GOOD.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU ALWAYS AIM
FOR MORE.
>> Jon: SO IT IS AN AMAZING
TRIBUTE TO YOU BUT HERE IS WHERE
YOU LINE UP.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
SO YOU HAVE PLEDGED, FOR
SCOTLAND, GREATER
SELF-DETERMINATION, MORE
FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE, BUT
NOW AFTER THE ELECTION, THAT
HAS CRASHED HEAD ON WITH THE
REALITY THAT WESTMINSTER
STILL CONTROLS THE PURSE
STRINGS, STILL BELIEVES IN
AUSTERITY AS RECEIPTS, CAN
DWINDLE FOR THE GDP OF
SCOTLAND.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THIS,
FIRST MINISTER.
WHAT IS HAGIS, WHAT IS THAT?
WHY --
(APPLAUSE)
WHY WOULD ANYONE --
>> HAGIS IS DELICIOUS.
YOU HAVE TASTED HAGIS?
>> Jon: THROUGH A HAZING,
YES.
>> IT'S WONDERFUL, YOU KNOW,
IT'S SPICY, IT'S TASTY, IT'S
ABSOLUTELY DELICIOUS AND YOU
GET VEGETARIAN HAGIS AS
WELL.
ANOTHER REASON TO COME TO
EDINBURGH.
SCOTLAND HAS SO MUCH TO
OFFER, WE'VE GOT SCOTCH
WHISKEY, WE'VE GOT HAGIS, WE'VE
GOT GREAT SCENERY.
WE'VE GOT WONDERFUL CITIES,
WE'VE GOT SOME GREAT COMEDIANS
OF OUR OWN, BUT WE CAN ALWAYS
HAVE ANOTHER ONE IN THE
EDINGBURGH FRIDGE, SO--
>> Jon: I'M HAPPY TO GO
THERE.
YOU KNOW, STOP PITCHING ME ON
SCOTLAND, LET ME PITCH YOU ON
AMERICA.
>> I LOVE AMERICA.
>> Jon: YOU HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A JONES FOR GETTING
OUT OF THIS WHOLE UNITED
KINGDOM.
WE WENT THROUGH A VERY
SIMILAR PROCESS.
LET ME TALK YOU THROUGH IT.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK WE'LL
TRY TO DO IT YOUR WAY.
>> Jon: LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
THEY HATE.
THEY HATE WHEN YOU THROW
THEIR STUFF INTO THE WATER.
>> THAT'S WHERE WE WENT
WRONG.
>> Jon: YOU HAVE TRIED THAT?
(APPLAUSE)
COME AND JOIN US.
WE CAN OFFER YOU A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT.
WHAT ARE THEY GIVING YOU.
U.K., WHAT IS THE HEALTH
PLAN, WHAT ARE THEY THROWING
YOU GUYS.
>> THEY'RE CUTTING OUR
BUDGET.
THEY'RE TAKING THINGS AWAY
FROM US.
>> Jon: ARE THEY REALLY
CUTTING YOUR BUDGET.
>> Jon: YOU HAVE SAID SCOTLAND
IS OKAY WITH THAT.
THAT YOU CAN BECOME
FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT, IS
THAT --
>> OF COURSE WE CAN
BE FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT.
I GUESS IF WE CAST OUR MINDS
BACK, ANY OF CAN REMEMBER IT
WHEN AMERICA WAS TRYING TO
BECOME INDEPENDENT OF THE
U.K. THERE WAS ALL SORTS OF
SCARY STORIES OF HOW IT WOULD
NEVER, EVER WORK.
I THINK AMERICA'S DONE OK
ACTUALLY, ON BALANCE.
YOU HAVE BECOME QUITE A
SUCCESSFUL, INDEPENDENT
COUNTRY.
SO YES, SCOTLAND COULD BE A
SUCCESSFUL, PROSPEROUS,
DYNAMIC INDEPENDENT COUNTRY.
I MEAN SCOTLAND IS ALMOST
INVENTED THE MODERN WORLD.
TELEVISIONS, TELEPHONES,
PENECILIN.
>> Jon: LET'S NOT GET NUTS
HERE.
>> ALL OF THESE THINGS WERE
INVENTED IN SCOTLAND.
SO OF COURSE, WE CAN STAND ON
OUR OWN TWO FEET.
> Jon: ANY LOOK AT WORLD
HISTORY, SCOTLAND IS USUALLY
FIRST MENTIONED.
>> INDEED.
>> Jon: IT GOES THAT, AND
THEN, YES.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
WHAT IS SO-- IF YOU WERE
GOING TO MAKE UP THAT MONEY,
AS AN INDEPENDENT SCOTLAND
THAT WANTS TO BE NUCLEAR
FREE, SO YOU'RE GOING TO  TAKE
AWAY THE TRIDENT, THE NUCLEAR
SUBS, WHERE IS THE MONEY GOING
TO COME FROM?
>> WE'VE GOT A BRILLIANT
ECONOMY SO WE ARE AN
OIL-PRODUCING COUNTRYMENT WE
HAVE RENEWABLE ENERGY.
>> Jon: GO BACK TO THE FIRST
ONE.
>> YOU'RE ABOUT TO TELL ME
THAT THE OIL PRICES GOT A BIT
LOWER --
>> Jon: I'M TO THE ABOUT TO
TELL YOU THAT AT ALL.
>> BUT WE'VE GOT RENEWABLE
ENERGY.
WIND, WAVE, TIDAL. WE EXPORT
FOOD AND DRINK.
>> Jon: GO BACK TO THE OIL.
>> YES, I WAS MOVING AWAY
FROM THE OIL.
>> Jon: BUT YOU HAVE OIL.
>> YES.
>> Jon: MAY WE INVADE YOU?
>> YOU DON'T USUALLY ASK
PERMISSION.
>> Jon: HOW MUCH CAN I SAY
THIS WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE SCOTTISH INDEPENDENCE,
AND THE NATIONALISTS, NOT
THE UNIONISTS, HOW MUCH OIL
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
>> NOT WORTH YOUR WHILE,
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> Jon: IT'S ALL WORTH OUR
WHILE.
>> I THINK IT IS PROGRESS
BECAUSE PRESUMABLY ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED STATES ASKING
PERMISSION TO INVADE AN
OIL-PRODUCING COUNTRY,
DOESN'T USUALLY WORK THAT
WAY.
>> Jon: HOW DIFFICULT HAS
THIS BATTLE BEEN WITH
NATIONALISTS AND UNIONISTS.
HAS IT-- IS IT A RED-BLUE
DIVIDE LIKE WE HAVE HERE.
HAS IT GOTTEN-- I KNOW IT
HAS ON TWITTER, HAVE YOU
THOGUHT ABOUT SECEDING TWITTER.
>> I THINK ABOUT SECEDING
FROM TWITTER ALMOST EVERY
DAY.
>> Jon: I THINK YOU SHOULD, IT'S
ROUGH TRADE.
BUT HOW DOES THAT GO, IS
IT SIMILAR GLASGOW IS SORT
OF THE HUB OF THE RURAL
AREAS ARE MORE UNIONISTS,
HOW DOES IT WORK.
>> GLASGOW WITH A CITY THAT
VOTED YES TO INDEPENDENCE,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, WE HURTLE
INSULTS AT EACH OTHER ON
TWITTER OCCASIONALLY BUT THE
INDEPENDENT REFERENDUM WAS
ENTIRELY DEMOCRATIC.
IT WAS PEACEFUL AND IT HAD
AN AMAZING LEGACY IN
SCOTLAND.
IN SCOTLAND WE'RE ACTUALLY
NOW REALLY INTERESTED IN
POLITICS, IMAGINE THAT.
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WANT TO
VOTE IN ELECTIONS.
THEY WANT TO GET INVOLVED.
THEY WANT TO GET A
POLITICIAN ON THE SPOT AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
DELIVERING PROMISES, THAT IS
A FANTASTIC THING.
DEMOCRACY HAS REALLY
BEEN STRENGTHENED BY IT.
>> Jon: OUR DEMOCRACY HERE
IS SO STRONG THAT WE DON'T
EVEN NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO IT.
IT'S SO POWERFUL, REALLY, 20,
30% OF US VOTE